[Musica]
[Applauso]
non credete a giancarlo ha detto una
marea di fesseria io sono un piccolo
insegnante di una piccola scuola
superiore o di una piccola città al sud
lecce e vorrei essere testimone del
fatto che ognuno di noi non importa
quanto sia grande quanto sia importante
può essere fautore e promotore di un
cambiamento
io ad esempio
pochi mesi fa come avete sentito anche
se mi hanno assegnato un premio
altisonante prestigioso come il global
fashion awards e mi hanno nominato
docente dell'anno del 2020 so per certo
di non essere una persona speciale so
per certo che qualsiasi insegnante
potrebbe meritare questi premi se solo
iniziasse ad avere un poco ed il
coraggio di pensare e agire fuori dalla
scatola
solo ho speso un po gli ultimi 20 anni a
cercare di capire quale quali fossero i
problemi della scuola ho speso 20 anni
per cercare di capire quale forma
dovremmo dare alla nostra scuola
l'oscura di cui abbiamo bisogno
anzi no quale forma di scuola i nostri
ragazzi hanno realmente bisogno
sono stati 20 anni di tentativi di
insuccessi
sono stati anni di sconfitta i
fallimenti ma sono stati anche anni di
grandi grandissime soddisfazioni e
successi soprattutto da parte dei nostri
studenti
dopo 20 anni credo di aver capito credo
di aver capito è insieme ai miei
colleghi due mesi fa abbiamo iniziato a
sperimentare una nuova forma di scuola
abbiamo iniziato a sperimentare una
scuola che abbiamo chiamato studenti
centrica la scuola studente centrica
ecco come dire con tutto il rispetto e
con tutte le dovute
immense differenze del caso se il grande
maestro da un altro da vinci ha pensato
di mettere l'uomo al centro
noi al centro il universo noi stiamo
pensando di mettere al centro
dell'universo scuola lo studente gli
studenti e voi direte come non c'è lo
studente al centro della scuola
no non c'è lo studente
alcuni pensano anche ci siano gli
insegnanti errato qualcun altro pensa
che siano le materie anche questo è
sbagliato
al centro a volte c'è l'intera classe ma
semplice il programma il programma da
svolgere come se fosse un protocollo da
marciare su lungo questo percorso
e per poi magari scoprire ad aprile di
essere in ritardo sul programma e allora
acceleriamo ancora di più per arrivare a
fine anno scolastico e poter dire con
orgoglio ho finito il programma
e chissenefrega se gli studenti se metà
della classe non è riuscita a stare al
passo
la scuola studenti centrica invece cerca
di mettere ogni studentesse e gli
studenti al centro e lo fa con due
percorsi innovativi il primo percorso
vede noi docenti impegnati a far salire
di gradino gli studenti nella scala dai
è anche il nome simpatico si tratta
praticamente di vedere gli alunni e
farli passare da demotivati perché i
nomi cast ci sono gli alluni demotivati
allo stato di attenti quelli sono nello
stato di attenti allo stato di
interessati i più bravi quelli bravi che
sono già nello stato di interessati
fargli fare un ulteriore passo in avanti
in uno stato che ancora non esiste che
quello degli esperti
magari con del programma di eccellenza e
qui pulirebbe e i voti allora questo
sistema non sostituisce i voti si
aggiunge ai voti e io sono certo per al
cento per cento
insegnanti ci concentriamo su questo
sistema i voti aumenteranno da sé ogni
gradino passato ogni passaggio da uno
stato all'altro è un successo
una conquista
il secondo percorso è quello di vedere
la scuola in tre forme nuove un attenti
e di stimoli un osservatorio di
interessi è una palestra di crescita
personale mi spiego meglio
la scuola a partire dalla prima media
fino al quinto superiore potrebbe
ospitare in classe una serie di
professionisti gli esperti gli operatori
nel mondo anzi di tanti mondi avere la
possibilità che la possibilità ai nostri
ragazzi di incontrare chi opera nella
moto dello sport nella tecnologia
dell'ecosostenibilità e poi il secondo
passaggio stare attenti a vedere quando
i nostri alunni si accendono i giochi
se a marta gli si accendono gli occhi a
sentir parlare una giornalista forse
abbiamo scoperto un interessa sia
giovanni mi si accendono gli occhi
quando vede una stampante 3d forse
abbiamo scoperto in interessa
terza fase come una palestra fornire
agli studenti strumenti e coach per
farli crescere in quel particolare campo
di interessa io sono sicuro che in
questo modo gli studenti vivranno la
scuola è un'istituzione tra le più
importanti della loro adolescenza come
una vera e propria rampa di lancio verso
il loro futuro
personalizzato e permettetemi di dirlo
un futuro che io immagino in cui saranno
più felici
noi a dir la verità in questi 20 anni
una forma grezza e artigianale di scuola
sua inter centi che l'abbiamo anche
applicato attraverso l'educazione
all'imprenditorialità
abbiamo incentivato
no troppo gentile abbiamo costretto i
nostri alunni dai 14 anni a inventarsi
una micro idea imprenditoriale vengono
chiamate star appoggi
e li aiutiamo a far sì che queste idee
realmente sul mercato non stiamo
parlando di simulazione parliamo di
piccole bere imprese in questi anni
abbiamo realizzato i nostri studenti una
cinquantina sino ad ora
tantissime sono miseramente fallite e
alcune sono sopravvissute per qualche
anno altre ancora
sono diventati delle vere e proprie
aziende poi ci sono i nuovissimi stanno
partendo in questi giorni e non sappiamo
ancora che fine faranno praticamente in
questa però fatemi raccontare qualche
storia in modo che vi sia un po più
chiaro lui e alberto paglialunga oggi ha
un po più di 30 anni e ha creato
un'azienda di e commerce dove vende
arredo bagno dove vende climatizzatori
dove vede degli arredi
non mi meraviglierei che tra di voi ci
fosse qualche suo cliente ha creato
questo e commerce nove anni fa si chiama
the kids e a nove anni di distanza
oggi l'azienda fattura 50 milioni di
euro all'anno
170 dipendenti sotto i 35 anni
200.000 clienti non c'è scritto sulla
slide ma dal lavoro a queste persone nel
salento non stiamo parlando praticamente
del nord est non stiamo parlando di
milano stiamo parlando delle porte di
lecce questo ragazzo è iniziato dal
garage di casa sua non nella silicon
valley a novoli e li vedete scritto
anche che ci sono tre premi ha in realtà
è lo stesso premio vinto per tre anni
dove viene premiato come miglior
ecommerce in italia
per il settore arredo e già questa è una
gran bella notizia ma la vera notizia è
che alberto ha vinto per tre anni ma il
secondo posto è arrivato il colosso ikea
isabella
giovanna benedetta francesco e sangue
hanno creato una nuova startup la
chiamano è questa eco isti
questo è qui in pratica stanno studiando
metodi nuovi per educare gli adulti a
rispettare l'ambiente a rispettare i
beni comuni ad oggi hanno ricevuto 3.000
euro di da sponsor e il progetto non è
ancora partito allo semplicemente
creduto nelle loro idea stanno lavorando
al lancio
dell'aggettivo è questa se fra qualche
mese qualche anno vi capiterà di leggere
da qualche parte un'azienda ecoist
all'azienda e questa dell'anno sappiate
che quell'aggettivo è stato tirato da
alcuni alunni di una scuola superiore e
stanno lavorando a creare 12 premi non
la riceve arriva a crearli vogliono
premiare ad esempio l'azienda e questa
dell'anno il personaggio è questo del
danno la scuola è questa dell'anno il
sindaco egoista dell'anno
poi ci sono in pratica questa intera
classe di quarto superiore di un quarto
quadriennale che sta lavorando
praticamente a creare un sito dedicato a
raccontare le storie di artigianato di
altissima qualità del territorio è una
start up nascente proprio in questi
giorni hanno considerato 18 categorie
diverse gli artigiani e hanno trovato
scovato 44 diversi artigiani ei ragazzi
adesso si stanno intervistando stanno
andando presso le botteghe per conoscere
loro storie per raccontarle e perché no
per poter vendere pratica i loro
prodotti sulla rete
questa classe invece nel 2016 avevano 14
anni hanno creato un movimento contro il
bullismo per la prima volta e credo oggi
ancora unica esperienza di ragazzi che
hanno creato un movimento di lotta al
bullismo è al cyberbullismo perché prima
volta perché la prima volta che succede
che lo fanno ragazzi perché sino ad oggi
la lotta al bullismo e sono vent'anni
che ne parliamo la facciamo noi adulti
ho fatto il ministero la polizia e
dirigente i docenti psicologi
però se siamo ancora qui a parlarne
probabilmente abbiamo fallito e allora
questi ragazzi hanno scovato un modo per
combattere il bullismo dal basso l'ha
inventato il modello ma basta volerlo ma
basta che ad oggi ha raccolto 45 mila
euro dal pubblico e dal privato allora
partecipa a qualsiasi genere di panto
bus sono tutte le porte e sono riusciti
con quei soldi a portare il loro modello
in 600 classi diversa 600 classi diverse
che hanno applicato il modello che hanno
sperimentato la manita del modello
sono stati in 16 regioni diverse e hanno
finto 23 premi in questi cinque anni
nazionali ed internazionali hanno vinto
l'open fab 2018 di bnp paribas cardiff
hanno vinto nel 2019 come miglior start
up studentesca d'europa dove tutti loro
concorrenti erano studenti universitari
erano gli unici liceali
in questo gruppo però c'è una storia
particolare quello di al centro lo
vedete quelle a mirko mirka cazzato
marco cazzato
e agli onori della cronaca perché appena
un mese fa il risultato che mirko è uno
dei dieci studenti più impattanti al
mondo grazie al global student price
sembra quasi fatto apposta ma qualcuno
di voi probabilmente ieri ha visto a
mirko ai soliti ignoti e la sera prima a
porta a porta perché è diventato
veramente il portabandiera italiano
dell'impegno sociale lui ha vent'anni
oggi ma a 5 anni alle spalle di una
bellissima start up sociale
lì un altro grande ha detto sì
cambiamento che vuoi vedere allora ci
pensavo da soggiorno e probabilmente
inconsciamente in questi anni io ho
cercato di creare di modellare la scuola
e farla diventare come io stesso avrei
voluto frequentarla c'è fare la scuola
che io avrei voluto frequentare e questa
è una cosa che tutti possono fare tutti
possono come dire impegnarsi a cercare
di fare un cambiamento
cercare di
vedere da top da subito pensare la
propria giornata vi svegliate il mattino
fate colazione
uscita andate al lavoro andate a scuola
passate il pranzo trascorrere il
pomeriggio
passate la sera la cera il dopo c'era di
nuovo andate a letto in questi percorsi
ogni qualvolta doveste trovare un
intoppo un problema
qualcosa che non va non vi lamentate
anzi potete lamentarvi
ma subito dopo il lamento cominciava
essere propositivi a pensare una
soluzione piccola microscopica perché
probabilmente quella soluzione che
andrete a cercare quella soluzione che
andrete a trovare potrebbe essere utile
a chi ci cento mille altre persone
alcune delle più belle start up sono
andato in questo modo per risolvere
piccoli problemi personali
e allora tu tu tu tutti quanti voi che
siete qui seduti davanti a me domani e
attenzione non lo ha detto un domani
domani domenica 21 novembre
cercate anche voi di essere fautori di
un piccolo cambiamento
perché se vi impegnate in questo senso
io sono sicurissimo che voi vostri figli
i vostri nipoti
troveranno un mondo più gentile un mondo
più rispettoso un mondo decisamente
migliore e avrete quella piccola grande
soddisfazione di aver contribuito
[Applauso]